5 years ago thanos erased half
of the population of the universe
but the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a snap of a finger
the sudden return of the population provided
the necessary energy for the emergence to begin
how long do we have seven days
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my full
marvel eternals trailer breakdown with all the
easter eggs and i'll explain the timeline of the
movie as it fits into sort of the origin of the
marvel cinematic universe or the sacred timeline
version of the marvel cinematic universe because
they do get into the actual big bang here you
kind of see the infinity stones scatter as
new galaxies are being born and also explain the
connection between the celestials in this movie
in galactus because galactus will be another
celestial in the cosmic mcu sense of things if
you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos it is going to be crazy for the
next couple of months between the marvel what if
episodes we have shangshi in the legend of the 10
rings the eternals movie and kevin feige finally
confirmed that we would actually be getting a
spider-man no way home trailer before the movie
came out like yes i've seen all your memes
but obviously at the beginning of this trailer
they're hyping up thanos why they didn't help
out during avengers end game i talked about that
during my last video but what's happening here
is when they're talking about the emergence
happening in seven days it's the emergence
of the next celestial that's growing inside planet
earth that's been gestating for millions of years
theoretically the whole idea being that it needs
cosmic energy to mature inside its celestial egg
but the energy given off by the snap sort of
supercharged that process so the idea is that
when salma hayek's ajax character who's kind
of the leader of the eternals is talking about
the immersions they show you this sort of cosmic
montage powerpoint presentation which is depicting
the birth of a celestial but a lot of you probably
realize this they're actually showing us the
actual big bang the quote-unquote beginning of the
timeline which we actually saw on the loki series
when you see this explosion and expansion of
different colors this is basically the big
bang that we're witnessing here and all these
different lights represent galaxies that are
forming around the universe after the big bang but
all these different colored lights are also meant
to represent the infinity stones because they
were also born from the remnants of the previous
version of the universe in the intro from loki
episode 6 is a good example of how to depict that
what happens at the end of the timeline or the
sacred timeline however you want to think about
it he who remains is talking about this is
that you have the heat death of the universe
and everything just kind of slowly expands like
galaxies just sort of break apart planets break
away from their suns and all life eventually
dies but then over time you have this slow
contraction where everything sort of coalesces
back into the single point the single black hole
which we're witnessing at the beginning of the
loki episode you have another big bang boom in
the universe is born again now when the he who
remains version of kang is talking about this he
engineered the timeline so that it would operate
on a time loop so that it would all be the same
that's why during the finale he kept talking about
seeing them again like oh we're just going to wind
up right back again inside this room if you kill
me but the whole idea that you need a massive
amount of cosmic celestial energy to grow a new
celestial or hatch a new celestial so to speak
is that during the big bang there was so much of
that cosmic energy present that it was enough to
birth many celestials and you have the birth of
the celestial host in the comics the actual cosmic
hierarchy goes like this eternity is the living
embodiment of the multiverse so that's the first
thing to come into existence along with galactus
if you're counting him because he's also from a
previous version of the universe but once eternity
gains consciousness it then creates the celestials
and then tasks them with growing life around the
universe they just go around using the infinity
stones cosmic energy to experiment with all
different kinds of life but also in that process
they try to create more celestials that process
takes millions even billions of years because it
takes so much cosmic energy and there just isn't
a lot of that cosmic energy present after the big
bang process has come and gone so you have to
imagine that there's a celestial growing inside
planet earth for millions of years just slowly
absorbing cosmic energy but also the really cool
explainer this is where we get to the x-men the
mutants of it all they're kind of riffing on this
idea in the comics that you have this celestial
inside planet earth is giving off this cosmic
radiation so to speak that slowly starts to mutate
human dna and eventually leads to the birth of the
x genes so to speak so like a lot of you are
looking at icarus and you're making superman
jokes but a lot of you are like wait a minute
that looks kind of like cyclops power too there
was a reference during what if episode 2 where the
collector is asking to challenge star-lord do you
shoot lasers out of your eyes and people are like
is that a cyclops x-men reference are you sure you
could not fly or shoot lasers out of your eyes or
something it's just one of the many ways it sounds
like they're going to explain mutants in the mcu
there's obviously the multiverse explainer too for
legacy characters that are coming from the fox
marvel universe like deadpool for instance but
the whole idea is the next thing the celestials
do is they create the deviants to then go around
and protect the life that they're creating
protect say for instance this celestial egg
they're growing inside planet earth but at least
within the context of the eternals movie in the
mcu the deviants go off the rails and they start
killing humans so then as cersei is explaining
their backstory to dane whitman about 7 000 years
ago the celestials create the eternals and then
send them to planet earth to protect the humans
because the deviants are trying to kill them off
really though they send them to protect the
celestial egg that's growing the leader of the
celestial host that's giving them these orders the
red celestial here that you see them all staring
at as they're sort of reincarnating getting this
celestial energy inside of them is arishem the
judge the same one she says told them not to
interfere in the affairs of man unless involved
the deviants so you have the idea that arishem the
judge doesn't really care about humans that much
only in so much as their feeding cosmic energy
to the growing celestial so even though the
deviants seem like they're the villains at first
glance in the trailer really it's the celestials
that are the actual villains here because
they're treating humans kind of like cattle
they're important important enough to protect
but only because they're kind of cosmic food
for the growing celestial so if it wasn't clear
the idea is that celestials did not send cersei
the other eternals to protect man from the deviant
7 000 years ago because they wanted to save humans
because they love them is because humans all over
the planet give off this low-level cosmic energy
that feeds into the celestial egg that's enough
for it to mature over millions of years and now
in seven days the eternals have to find a way to
either stop the celestial from actually hatching
out of its egg or find a way to hatch it in a way
that won't completely destroy the planet another
world ending disaster right after avengers
end game here we go again the way she talks
about it like five years ago makes it sound like
this is happening literally right after avengers
end game but it sounds like the main reason why
they're justifying the other avengers not getting
really involved in this movie like they referenced
them a lot but you don't see any actual other
avengers characters running around is because
one the eternals have been waging this shadow war
protecting humans from deviants for thousands and
thousands of years on the dl trying to stay off
the radar but two it's so soon after iron man's
funeral after the end of avengers end game that
all the avengers characters all the characters
from avengers end game are still kind of in trauma
mode in processing that so for instance talking
about the timeline three weeks after avengers
end game is when the events of Wandavision episode
one pick up falcon in winter soldier for instance
doesn't take place till after six months after
avengers end game spider-man far from home doesn't
take place till 8 months after avengers end
game so it's a long time after avengers end game
that's why spider-man no way home is almost
like a year and a half after avengers end game
the loki series is a little bit different because
of the way it takes place all over the timeline
but you have to assume that loki is picked up by
the tva right during the ending of avengers end
game is that's ending then they jump to the end
of the timeline they wind up killing kang thank
you very much sylvie in creating or unleashing
the true version of the multiverse and all the
kang variants so if you wanted to get really
technical about it yes what's happening with loki
the multiverse the changing of the sacred timeline
the birth of the true version of the multiverse or
unleashing of the true version of the multiverse
is all happening while the events of the seven
days of the eternals movie is happening but i
don't think that marvel is going to get too much
into that during the eternals movie just in the
name of simplicity just because like the casual
viewer would just get way too confused if you
tried to introduce all this crazy time travel
addressing the deviance of it all because cersei
says we're not supposed to get involved unless
it involves the deviants but technically thanos
does carry the deviant gene he's a cousin of the
eternals he's an eternal from titan his father was
an eternal that actually was born on planet earth
and then just left and colonized titan eventually
but i think you could pin this all on ayrshim the
judge in the celestial host because their only
interest is in giving birth to this new celestial
they would have known about the infinity stones
that were present on earth also further feeding
more cosmic energy to the growing celestial so the
idea that someone would bring an infinity gauntlet
and unleash even more celestial cosmic energy to
help their new celestial grow they would actually
probably be pretty excited about they don't
really care about the collateral damage from
the snap killing off half of all life if it means
it's going to grow more celestials and even though
you joke about thanos going around erasing half of
all life on each planet the slow way before he got
the infinity stones in the infinity gauntlet the
celestials do that on the regular they wipe out
life on planets when they deem the experiment
to be a failure that's why arishem the judge
is called arishem the judge because he goes around
judging life around the universe that they've been
experimenting on like okay we judge you to be
a failure so we're just going to wipe the slate
clean like you see eson the searcher in guardians
of the galaxy movie wiping out life on that planet
with the power stone now also theorize that could
have something to do with releasing cosmic energy
to try and grow another celestial inside the
planet like not only are you wiping out life but
when you use an infinity stone like that you're
unleashing a massive amount of cosmic energy that
could be absorbed by a growing celestial there
were a lot of you that were also asking about
a thanos connection to what was happening
with thena and Kro's storyline in the movie
because they had this weird relationship in the
comics and Kro who's the leader of the deviants
here is talking to her like you can't save them
it seems like there's this creepy thing going on
between the two of them some of you were like what
if Kro plus thena equals thanos and that's how
he got his deviant genes that's not where thanos
comes from but thanos is directly related to thena
biologically through their grandfather so he does
actually share some genetic material with thena
more so than the other eternals characters they
dealt with this idea in the comics recently but i
think they're going to address it during the movie
the idea that the eternals will discover the real
reason why they were actually sent to planet earth
in that the celestials don't care about humans and
they're about to be wiped out and they rebel
against the celestials to try and save humans
under the threat that arishem the judge
is going to bring the celestial host and
judge planet earth and just wipe all life out
in order to help birth this new celestial now
i talked about jamiah the analyzer the other big
celestial that we see during the trailer and the
idea that he could theoretically be nowhere the
head of the dead celestial it could have belonged
to him at one point in history there are other
members of the celestial host that we see during
the movie that showed up in the concept footage
but you don't really see in the trailer there's
nezzar the calculator hargen the measurer then you
have obviously eson the searcher who is part of
the celestial host and a lot of you are now asking
where does ego the living planet another celestial
figure in to the celestial host in air shown the
judge's mission so in the comics ego the living
planet is not a celestial he's just another one
of the elders of the universe the mcu has changed
that a little bit but the way they narrate ego
the living planet's backstory during guardians
of the galaxy 2 is that ego says that he was just
born out of nothingness he never really understood
what was going on until he gained consciousness
and then eventually learned the ability to form
mass around himself thus he became ego the living
planet so you have to imagine that during the big
bang here that they depict during this and you
see this cosmic energy swirling around and the
celestials being born the original celestial host
while this is happening ego the living planet is
also busy being born but he does not become part
of the celestial host he's kind of like a rogue
celestial just left to his own devices but it's
the same concept the celestials are trying to make
more of themselves ego the living planet another
celestial was trying to make more of himself
at the expense of all lesser life forms like
humans so ego the living planet a villain during
guardians of the galaxy 2 the celestials a villain
in the cosmic sense of things so to speak but only
from the viewpoint of lesser life forms like
the avengers the humans the eternals characters
it's a familiar concept he who remains sort of
dealt with this during the loki series where
he was talking to them you think that i'm the
devil but i'm protecting you if you think i'm bad
wait till you meet my variants think of the same
thing with the celestials like irishman the judge
if you think i'm bad wait till you meet the others
and that other just happens to be galactus like
galactus is not a variant of ayrshin the judge
but he's probably going to be another celestial
in the mcu but going forward after this movie
you have the whole idea of the eternals are
going to be rebelling against the celestials
then obviously they're not paying attention to
irish and the judge's rules about interacting
interfering with humans that paves the way for
them to cross over with the avengers in avengers
5. and kevin feige actually thankfully did talk
about when they're going to do avengers 5. he
basically made the comparison to marvel phase one
he said you introduce some characters you slowly
create a problem that necessitates that they come
together to solve it we're in marvel phase four
now they're introducing a bunch of new characters
we're starting to slowly see some bigger
cosmic problems with kang the multiverse war
and that sounds like it's going to be the
reason why the avengers or the new avengers
assemble again which makes it sound like avengers
5 is going to be that secret wars movie that
we're talking about i'll do more videos about
avengers 5 the more he talks about it but he's
pretty cagey when people ask him questions about
stuff that far out so hopefully that explains how
everything fits together obviously there's a
lot of other big questions from the movie you
have all the kit harrington black knight stuff
that'll play out through the eternals movies we
have shang chi the legend of the ten rings which
also takes place after avengers end game if that
wasn't clear if you haven't seen my non-spoilery
review i do explain that during that video i don't
really consider that a spoiler i think pretty
much everything else i covered in my reaction
video so i'll link that at the end of this but
if there's any questions that you have that i
haven't addressed in my eternals video so far
just write them below in the comments everyone
click here for my other eternals trailer video and
click here for my full marvel what if episode 2
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!